welcome to them you spoil a show I'm
your host definition and I just want to
give a huge thank you everyone for
subscribing the channel I'm really just
blown away by the hundred thousand
subscriber milestone for those of you
that have been following me sense of
style I basically started uploading
movie videos about three years ago it
was within the last year that I hit a
thousand subscribers and to see it grow
to this now I'm just completely blown
away by it thanks to everyone's support
I've never had to ask for a patreon and
it's all because you guys just check out
the videos leave comments and likes and
it just means more than I can really put
into a blog I really appreciate
everything that everyone does and you
helped to build the channel as much as I
do I'm constantly seeing all the same
names in the chat and I just feel like
I've got a great group of fans and it's
brilliant talking to all of you each and
every day I also just want to give a
huge thank you to everyone behind the
scenes who helps to make the videos
whether they provide music guidance or
you know just put me in the right
direction towards story and it means a
whole hell of a lot so I massively
massively appreciate it I also just want
to thank my competition as well as some
absolutely amazing content creators out
there who really pushed me to be better
so thanks to everyone and yeah just
thank you so much for supporting the
channel and it turns out in the end that
Bruce Willis was a ghost the whole time
so for more spoilers like that I'm gonna
blow your mind make sure you subscribe
and thanks again guys Cheers this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you be the best
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you